wow
that is fantastic
this is the sound of a snake going up
emily's ass
no come on
i like your movies more okay oh come on
man don't make me flash up here
i mean some of our favorites was the uh
the big short wait that wait what no no
it's not my hip-hop hobbit that's good
that's not that's not my movie
i never did that speaking of arnold he
has a cameo in the rundown right and uh
he did he called me up and he's like
i'll rock let me tell you something i
saw you on conan o'brien
[Applause]
who's most likely to survive a real-life
jungle cruise adventure that would be
new because you have more fat on you
so you'd last longer
look at everybody's head popped up when
you think of the greatest comedians of
all time even stand-up comedians you
have
it when you think of comedic rock stars
that's kind of it you guys want to bring
it over y'all burning it back
to bring it back
david chappelle wow
you be me i'll be you okay here we go
pump up a little bit good good all right
can you uh yeah i can't do that much
more than that yeah
this is me being you it's just
all right oh that's good can you make
yourself a little bigger in here yeah
is it hard for you guys to sit next to
each other today for a chat i thought so
emily my heart goes out to you
this one doesn't use deodorant so you
can imagine that wow oh i'm kidding
that's the headline arms down
take one of the hibiscus italy
get one of the flowers
that makes it worse though big time
snore
still coming out now okay well you fart
in your sleep how about that well that's
a different situation he farts in his
sleep gas x it's uh not my best friend
whatever he sleeps with a diaper he's a
person all right this is a personal
problems that nobody needs to know
owning this look i had a turtleneck i
had mom jeans on i was wearing a face
we've got the picture here oh no there
you are
it's a strong look it's it's something
seth rogen was on the show yeah and he
showed us his version here's seth rogen
as it
check this out and don't be afraid to
check it out this is i got a chest put
your hand on that okay put your hand on
that what are you feeling i feel abreast
who is the funniest person in the cast
jack probably no you her because with
her british sense of um no as she likes
to say no i don't
big fan of all of his movies well yeah i
loved all of his movies that's the thing
i mean home alone and no yeah i love
that one those are beverly hills cops
eddie murphy
[Applause]
if you saw me let's say you weren't
dwayne the rock johnson you're a guy
okay and you're in a
you see me and i'm mouthing off and i'm
not coming at you would you be at all
worried be honest to be honest with you
i
i would think i'm gonna [ __ ] this guy up
that's just to be honest what am i
scared what are you scared of not a
thing
nothing nothing nothing
not about in real life like out of the
jungle just in life
a lot of people are gonna see this
interview nothing
if there was a jumanji league of
superheroes and dwayne you were black
adam karen was nebula and jack was nacho
libre who would kevin be
anki pete
he'd be honky pete what would his
superpowers be i'd be black adam look at
a honky peter
[Laughter]
you know how sometimes when people get
under your skin and you just hate them
i'm not what are you saying it's you i'm
just saying there's some times where you
just really hate somebody sometimes you
have that personality when you walk in
and you're like you think everyone's
like hey there's kevin great but you
know do you have nicknames for each
other yes don't
eat i do a nice one oily
what
i'm kevin hart right right in high
school okay um yeah hey hey hey
hey everybody hey
hey girl
hey girl
hello
come on
come on
hey miss johnson yeah
i'm gonna do good on that test
yes uh moonlight and the oscars it is
now kind of stuff of legends the the end
when they write out the wrong name and
matt damon like a fly could find me
shell wouldn't look shocked but i don't
think anyone is quite as concerned
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know if you're lucky enough you get
a chance to
make a movie for disney that is based
off an iconic disney ride and on top of
that uh you know co-star was someone who
i've loved and admired over the years
gal gadot no
oh
i do not like it
because you have you dress clean fresh
everything is cool and when you talk
it's like yeah
did did you get your butt what
waxed my butt
that's what i did yeah i have my wax
once every thursday in the morning after
breakfast here we are central
intelligence they shut us down the fire
trucks are out here will you get the
[ __ ] out of my video
what are you doing
i'm trying to do my best this is my
video you're in my [ __ ] video watch
your mouth
[ __ ] you all right here we go wait we
should thank the people that's too right
hey real quick before we start this
record-breaking uh internet stream
event
we didn't give it a title it's it's it's
it's a record-breaking yeah internet
stream yes historic event movement yes
historic event moments
with the rock and kevin no we're kevin
hart
in the pebble
no no oh don't laugh at that
dwayne
it is kevin the hitman heart
and the bald guy
yes yes it is the rock up in this [ __ ]
and chocolate
[Music]
hey if you if you just tuned in to this
live stream we got kevin mother [ __ ]
heart
in
him
that's true that's true and for the
world who's tuning in because this is
going to be the biggest live stream ever
we got the rock in the [ __ ]
house
we
got kevin long faced little butt lou
aka my shoes are red and he's on fire
because he walks real fast and his
shoulders are broad and he's got good
skin and he's the people person
we got the [ __ ]
hey guys just hanging out with the iron
paradise here's the thing the cast that
trains together stays together let's get
it
wait
okay uh let's go watch some quidditch no
wow
a mary poppins never ever no yes it's
cool
it's like negativity okay come on let's
talk about it
oh there it is